hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are going
over lead code how to use it how to use
it effectively and how
to really prepare for the technical
interview
with this resource this is what i used
when preparing for technical interviews
and i highly recommend it so let's get
to it so right away after you create an
account you're taken to this like
news feed page i highly recommend
creating an account because that's
how you'll see your progress you'll see
all the challenges you've done before
all your saved work
and all of that it's really going to
allow you to get the most out of this
we're going to focus on these three
main pages explore problems and mock
so starting off with explore you're kind
of taken to
this choose your own adventure
type page where you can pick to practice
based on
a certain coding challenge or based on a
certain
topic or based on
interviews a company you're interviewing
for and so that
first banner is really a mix of all of
those
but scrolling down a little bit
this is where we see that section for
interviews so we have google facebook
amazon
apple and you see here it's all for
premium
members and so you'll need to pay for
lead code to access these things
and so if you are interviewing for
places like microsoft
like facebook and you're new to
development or you're new to
interviewing then i can see the benefit
of going distraught
and getting that premium membership but
if you're not
then i kind of truly think you can get
away
with not going these routes unless
you're specifically interviewing for
facebook etc
and i say that because i didn't have a
premium membership
but i still had access to all of these
amazing
resources and so moving on to the learn
section you can choose coding challenges
you can choose
your path based on the specific subject
and so if you want to learn about linked
lists
or binary trees or recursion
this is where you can do that really
focusing your learning
on the specific subject or maybe in
general you just don't know much about
binary trees
or you don't know much about the
recursion
this is a great way to learn that and
test your skills
there this is also great if you know a
company is going to test recursion going
to test or raise going to test
linked lists and so that is another way
you can go about studying
and then finally we have the challenge
section and this is great if you
have trouble staying consistent and you
need that extra push to
be consistent to be on it and so with
the challenge you have you know
january leeco challenge december etc so
that
you can make sure that you're following
along with this
material and staying on top of it
because consistency really is
key here now going up to really where i
lived um
for a couple of months and that's the
problems section
so the problem section is real exactly
what that is just a bunch
of problems each of them one single
problem
and if you see here they're
really sectioned out by acceptance
difficulty and so you can choose a
problem
based on those things so the acceptance
kind of indirectly tells you the
complexity of the problem
it says of all the people who submitted
problems who submitted solutions only
46.7
were accepted by leak code which means
there's a whole
53 percent that weren't accepted so it
can be a good
gauge for complexity
and so i typically always sorted by
difficulty
and then clicked on acceptance so that
it was from highest to lowest because it
could be easy but then it can still be
complicated and so this is how i would
go through the problems and if you see
there's
loads and loads of problems to go
through here which is why i say you
don't really need
the premium subscription and so this
first one has a 95.6
acceptance rate which can really tell
you that is probably the easiest problem
you'll find
and this one's locked because you need
to be a premium member and so all the
ones you see that have that lock symbol
you need to be a premium member but look
at all the ones that don't
have that locked symbol you truly don't
need that subscription
to get the most out of your experience
so let's start with this problem
number of good pairs
and so this is our interface this is
how each problem will be presented to us
with the name
of the problem along with the
description
and then the example so here we say
given an
array of integers nums a pair i
j is called good if nums i equals nums j
and i is less than j return the number
of
good pairs and so then if we go down we
see examples
and constraints and i really love this
interface because from my experience
this is
kind of always how coding challenges
were presented
to me they had this entire layout
of the description and then examples
and then a space to input your solution
and so it was great practice
in terms of actually getting that real
world experience so that i wouldn't be
caught off guard
when it was time to interview
and even when it was a one-on-one
interview the person was actually
there there still would be
this interface provided so that
everything was clear
and all of that so this is great and
then
here you can input your solutions or
test out solutions and all of that
now first thing you'll want to do here
is check the coding language
and so for me this is total gibberish i
really
cannot read this and so i'm going to
change it to javascript
that's where that's typically the coding
language i use
now keep in mind make sure you're paying
attention to the type of interview
you have received if you're interviewing
for front end role
it's probably not the best idea to be
coding out in
c plus plus because front end
is javascript and so keep that in mind
when you're practicing if you're
interviewing for both back and front end
roles then you
should be switching around and making
sure you can answer the questions um
in all the different types of languages
and typically you
are given the option to choose your
language but it also
says a lot the language you choose so
we're not actually going to solve this
we're going to go into discuss
which i also lived here because it's
great for seeing how other people
solved this problem if you're stuck if
you're not sure what to do or even if
you solved it but you're looking
at ways it could have been better this
is a great thing to do and so if you
pick the language you're working in
me it's javascript look at how many
solutions are posted
up by users and there's seven whole
pages
and there's just so much and so let's
start off by picking
one to look at so let's see here
let's do just the first one so we see
the solution
that this person put up we see that okay
there's a let there's a for loop
then another for loop and then he
returns
count so this is a great way to kind of
see
how other people interpreted the problem
see if you understand the solution that
they provided
and if you're stuck it's a great way to
get unstuck because you see
oh okay i understand for loops and they
did this then they
went for the nums length then they
incremented
count by one if i equal j
and it's just a great way to kind of
just
go through that solution to kind of go
through
that problem solving seeing okay i get
it now so let me
wipe the solution out let me exit out of
this and try it myself without looking
at this and
can i make it make sense for me now if
we go
to other solutions okay so we see here
this is a lot
this is very different from the first
one
now this is where you can get into
trouble don't try
to find the most fancy solution find
the thing that looks most impressive
let's say you don't know what a for each
is you don't know what dot set does
etc that can get you into trouble if
you're just copying the solution and
pasting that's not gonna
help you during the interview what you
could do
is use your confusion to say okay let me
google what 4-h is let me google what
dot set is
and learn how this solution came
together
but yeah going through the different
solutions going through the more
complicated ones the simpler ones etc
it's a great way for you to learn from
the people around you because
on the job that's what you should be
doing to strive to be learning from
people strive
to be doing better because you see
someone else's process somebody else's
code but again don't be copy and pasting
this
and calling it good without knowing any
which way what's
going on and so let's
exit out of this and try to find
yeah a solution that works for us so we
go back to discuss
my bed there we go back
and let's try to select that first
problem again i think
it's a great beginner friendly solution
let's copy this
and paste i definitely don't recommend
copying pasting even if you find a
solution
that you resonate with i recommend
typing it out because that's the best
way you'll
learn but for the sake of this tutorial
we'll copy and paste it
and then we'll go down here and select
run code
which puts the solution through
one of leak codes tests
and if we click submit it will go
through all of their tests and see if it
passes all of them
and it does and we see here it gives us
information as to the runtime and memory
usage so runtime it says it was five
percent faster
than other submissions which is not the
best
that is not that is not good but the
memory usage
is less than 91 now focusing
on that runtime the 5.07 percent
it's very important to see why that is
and to see
ways to make it better and then for
memory usage
91.08 that's pretty
good so we can focus our efforts into
that runtime and in interviews that's
really where our focus will be
trying to see how to make good quality
code that
runs quickly because that's important
for our
users or our hypothetical users if we
get the job
so if we look here at the solution we
can see this embedded
for loop here now that is a huge
no-no that is a huge no-no because it
produces if you've heard of time space
complexity
this produces a time complexity of o
of n squared because of this embedded
for loop
and that's something you would be
expected to talk about in an interview
in interviews i've never really been
expected to talk about space complexity
but time complexity oh you must much at
least
touch on and so if you have a solution
that's
of n squared it's very important to find
ways to
make it less than that and that's
another reason why this discussion board
can be so so useful finding solutions
that
are faster than this 5.07 percent or
this of n squared solution and so
but keep in mind if this is your very
first problem
honestly this is great the fact that you
got to a solution
is fantastic and so this the time space
complexity piece
can be something you focus on later
right now your focus can be really just
solving problems and
figuring out ways to solve it and all of
that and then getting to that
added layer later on
and so going back to the problems page
and if we re organize the
difficulty of easy and if we scroll down
we can now see a check mark
for that problem saying good job we
solved it one of
problems we're making our way making our
way downtown y'all
but yes there's just so many problems we
can go through and so that's why i say
yeah if you are just consistent and
you're going through
you'll be good you don't need that
premium membership
but then going to mock this provides
mock interview questions from quo
unquote
real companies and this can be great if
you are interviewing for a specific
top-tier company like facebook amazon
microsoft
but again you will need that premium
subscription
and so yeah for me it's only
that premium subscription is only worth
it if that is
your situation if that is the
circumstances in which
you are in but then you do have a few
random ones
here but yeah i typically just live in
the problem section y'all like i truly
just was very consistent made goals of
let's do
three a day or let's do ten a week the
number
you put as to how many you want to solve
really just depends on your goals your
timeline when you'll get your
interviews when you're looking to start
interviewing and so
really see what that timeline looks like
and sit down and go through that
but yeah that's really it y'all
let's log out here i created a separate
account for this to really show a
beginner experience is like
but there we go there we go everybody a
very
detailed look into how to best use leak
code i hope
this was helpful if it was please leave
a like subscribe
and i'll see y'all later bye